elect biden plans to announce the first
members of his cabinet tomorrow
cbs news confirms he has selected
long-time aid and diplomat tony blinken
to be his secretary of state nicole
killian is in wilmington delaware
covering
the biden transition nicole what do we
know about mr blinken
anthony tony blinken had long been
considered a front runner for the
secretary of state position he's been
working with the president-elect
on global issues and previously served
as deputy
secretary of state during part of the
obama administration he is seen
in a photo during the osama bin laden
raid
he was also national security adviser to
then vice president biden
cbs news has also learned the
president-elect plans to nominate linda
thomas greenfield as ambassador to the
united nations
she is currently leading mr biden's
agency review team for the state
department
she was the former assistant secretary
of state for african affairs
and one of the highest ranking black
diplomats
at the department now one hitch in the
president-elect's transition
process is that none of his nominees can
get
background checks until the general
services administration
signs off on the formal transition
process so far the agency has not
changed
its posture but many democratic
lawmakers have demanded
that the gsa administrator brief them by
today
tony all right nicole thank you very
much